so what we should really talk about next
is how teams use git because that's the
other function git protects your code
from other people
in a way right so it's designed to stop
you know if say there's a company with
like 100 developers in it and they're
all working on different parts of the
code base and that code base is stored
in a git repository it's got to find a
way to
make sure that developer number 50
doesn't overwrite the code of developer
number 12 when they're working on like
the same area
so this involves a mixture of things
this involves get protecting code when
you're trying to do get pushes and get
commits but it also involves um
coordination between people and so one
thing one of the main reasons you will
see things like github and get labs
being used is because those products
those kinds of online websites provide
you with lots of other features that are
sort of
added around git functionality to help
you communicate with each other and
coordinate
um so let's talk about first
the get pushes and get commits and what
would happen in practice
so if you have two developers and
they're both being tasked on fixing a
bug at the same time
and to fix that bug they both need to
make a change to one particular file so
maybe i'm editing files one two and four
and he's editing files three five and
four but we're both gonna edit file four
at some point this becomes a situation
that git needs to manage for you
so if person one
edits those three files including file
four creates a git commit and pushes
them to the server that's fine the
server will accept it because there
hasn't been any updates from anybody
else
it's fine with that
the second person will create their git
commits and then type in git push and
then the server will say no
you can't do that because from the last
time you downloaded the latest version
someone else has added more content so
your version is out of date basically
and it will force you to get yours up to
date before it will let you push so this
is a really handy feature it's
protecting
the code by stopping one person
overwriting someone else
so then what you have to do is
type git pull if you're that second
person there's actually you could do a
couple of things you can do git fetch
which downloads uh metadata about what
has changed and then you can manually
and carefully merge things or you can
just type in git pull and it will pull
down the latest version and it will try
to automatically merge everything
so for those separate files that you
both edited and even if you're in one
file and you edited different bits of
the file
git will say when you download the
latest version and say great i can merge
your changes with the latest version and
just does it for you
but if you both edit the same sort of
area and get isn't sure
it's very good then it says well okay i
can't do that i'm not smart enough
uh as a bit of software we need a human
who is more smart to um tell me what
should have happened here so
what it will do is it will add both of
your lines of code into the file with
like some metadata above it you see a
bunch of side arrows
and then the word head and then you see
the first person's code and then you see
like a separator in the middle and the
second person code
and then some other line
arrows facing the other way
to show the last the commit you've been
making and it will say okay as a
as a human you tell me which ones keep
or if i should keep a bit of both
you know
figure it out intelligently and so your
job then is to delete the metadata lines
and delete the lines of code that don't
need to be there anymore and do the
merge
cleverly as a human
so that's
it's sometimes a painful process it
involves you communicating maybe with
the other human to make sure that you
know why did you do that why did i do
this you know do we need to keep both
that sort of thing
and then once you've merged it you can
then create a new commit and then you
can push the server hoping that no one
else has pushed something in the
meantime
um but it's your job as a developer to
make sure that you're going to push
something that doesn't break other
people and get helps you do that by
saying no
because i can imagine that if you're two
developers working for say someone like
youtube and you're both working on the
code base for youtube servers if you
need to sort of
subtly adjust that
that could affect nearly everybody
working on all the different areas so
yeah for sure in principle you're right
that there's these bits that might get
reused by lots of people
in practice those bits would also be
quite carefully protected either through
procedure or through because one thing
you can do is you can um
limit people to pulling areas of code
you know or sub projects within git on
the server so that not everybody is
doing and some bits which are really
crucial that are going to affect
millions of users you know they will
have serious protection lines and that's
actually the best thing we should talk
about next is um
the kind of process that teams go
through to make sure they coordinate
who's doing what
so companies like github and gitlab
they have added these extra features
like milestones and issues issues are
like tickets
things that need doing
and so um
what they'll say is okay here's a ticket
that needs like a bug that needs fixing
or a new feature we want to add and
we'll assign it to a person or a set of
people
and those people will be responsible for
writing the codes that will
resolve that ticket so what they'll do
in practice actually is kind of
interesting the team is most likely to
then create a temporary branch which
we've talked about before with the idea
of that ticket is this kind of his name
because you could otherwise you'd have
millions tickets millions of numbers so
you name the branch after the kind of
ticket you're trying to fix the issue
you're trying to fix
and then um as a group you will work
only on that version that's set aside so
you're not disrupting the main version
of your software you're not disrupting
the main branch you're working on like
this side developer branch just for this
particular issue
and then you will all kind of work on
that finish it test it yourself properly
and then you will
um push that code onto the server and
then you will create what's called a
merge request or a pull request
depending on what whether you're using
githubgitlabs they've got slightly
different language what that really then
says is
uh
we want a senior developer
to
check it's all okay and then merge it if
it's fine and that's that job is
normally reserved for someone who's
they've got the authority to check
something and check his goods and also
to put it do something risky like merge
it with the product you're about to
release
you know some more senior people may be
given that job
and so you can ask git
lab or github to uh notify people that
like a
new set of code for an issue is ready to
review and companies will have review
processes that are they're required to
do like someone will check that it meets
legal standards someone will check that
the code structure conforms to the
company's standards and that sort of
thing and people say yes this looks fine
to me yes it's fine to me or no go back
and do more and it creates a
conversation it forces them to have a
conversation
and then only when they're happy with it
the senior person will do the job of git
merge
and merge it into
some sort of main main version of the
software
what you find in some companies they
will have the main version which is like
their release product and they'll have
like a release candidate
branch and the people who are doing
their fixes are branching from that
branch
and so they make sure the side one works
and then only then at some point the
future this okay
this is a release ready version that we
have collectively built
and then someone really important
we'll carefully make that a public thing
for someone to use
so lots of companies will
uh protect what's the main branch or
protect different versions um and they
won't give permissions to types of users
like developers
to push directly to that because that
will break it
so
we might break it they're really worried
that people will just push a version and
delete or you know delete something
critical to the main version of the
software so all these protections and
processes are put in place to help teams
collaborate
but i mentioned earlier that sometimes
they create like a beta version and they
name the version with the git tag like a
beta release ready or release candidate
what they're doing is they're releasing
the software
to a set of authorized users who are
able to download that beta version
and then hopefully there's more expert
sort of known beta users will say oh i
found something that breaks and then let
you know before you release it to the
whole world
and you can actually do that with
chromium which we talked about before
because on chromium you can download the
latest beta version you can download the
latest release candidates you can
download the
the final version they end up with
yesterday so you can choose a developer
to go and get these potentially buggy
versions and help them to debug it by
being part of a sort of
smaller known community and all the
people that don't know what beta is in
practice
they just download official releases
that chrome tells them to
update when they're told to update so um
it is handy having these kind of
first set of people that will try
something to show that it breaks which
is normally like your own developer
community and then a slightly broader
community you're happy to have the beta
version of and then when it's been
tested by lots of people
then it goes out because of course there
are benefits in having the beta version
it might have new features that uh you
know nobody else has got right yeah and
so like i know a lot of computer science
students are always happy to get like
the latest beta version and for a while
i was subscribing to the latest release
candidate of
mac os x
and uh that was fine until like the
first release candidate for two weeks
they broke apple mail you know and which
you know if people were using this on
test machines that wouldn't matter
because i was using it on my main work
machine and suddenly i couldn't use
apple mail for two weeks but you know as
a
person who's happy to test release
candidates or beta versions you expect
that stuff maybe doesn't work entirely
you get early access to features that's
maybe exciting and probably you're
technically confident enough to not
worry if something breaks or you know
delete your beta version and then
download the proper version if you
really need it
so what happens is
so we'd have to go over here
across the distributed shared memory
link
to get the value and then we could bring
the value back so rather than taking 100
nanoseconds
just trying to get packets from one lab
to another obviously by 1986 we've got
lots of things in europe